an internal attentional focus is a focus
on some component of a movement and so
um
most often in the term
in the context of lifting when you think
about an internal attentional focus it's
generally like focusing on
feeling a particular muscle working or
contracting so you know if you're doing
bicep curls instead of just trying to to
maximize performance on bicep curls
you're really focusing on squeezing the
biceps feeling it get a good contraction
that's an internal attentional focus
versus an external attentional focus
that's a focus on the outcome of a
movement so
you know in the case of bicep curls
you're not necessarily trying to feel
your biceps get the best contraction
possible you're you're you have a weight
in your hands and you're trying to
uppercut someone as explosively as
possible with it
um so yeah i think probably the
the external cue
that people in powerlifting would be the
most familiar with is in bench press
just throw the bar through the ceiling
that's a that's a classic external cue
um so yeah those those are kind of the
broad differences in internal versus
external attentional focus strategies
and what this meta-analysis wanted to do
is look at the evidence related to the
impact of internal versus external
attentional focus on acute strength
performance but then also
changes
longitudinal changes in strength and
performance over time um
and so
in terms of the acute meta-analysis they
came up with one two three four five six
seven
eight uh eight studies i think it was
eight uh different groups and seven
studies um looking at the impact of
internal versus external attentional
focus on strength performance and they
found that in external attentional focus
did
improve strength performance relative to
an internal focus
which isn't surprising that is what one
would predict
but it is actually good to see and the
reason i say that
is
most of the research on attentional
focus
isn't hyper specific to strength
outcomes so there's a really really
broad body of research on internal
versus external attentional focus on
performance and acute neuromuscular
outcomes but most of it is more looking
at
things like jump height which is
somewhat related to maximal strength
performance but then also more just kind
of like fine motor skills so or i guess
this would be more like gross motor
skills but like bean bag tossing so you
know do you focus on
the the the
like pendulum arc of your arm as you
toss the bean bag which would be an
internal focus or do you just kind of
like stare at the target where you want
to toss the bean bag and and to focus on
the outcome of the movement like that um
and so there's there's a lot of uh
just kind of like neuromuscular research
looking at sort of like accuracy based
goals finding that external attentional
focus uh produces better outcomes but
like i said a lot of that isn't isn't
directly related to strength performance
but there's now enough research looking
at the acute impact of internal versus
external attentional focus
on maximal strength performance that we
can meta-analyze these studies and find
that yeah an external attentional focus
acutely enhances strength performance
not you know it's not gonna like double
your bench press but the pooled effect
size was like point three point four
something like that so that's a that's a
small but notable effect
you know we would like to assume that
anything that acutely enhances
performance will also
chronically lead to larger performance
enhancements over time um
but in a lot of cases there's not great
longitudinal evidence to support the
ongoing usage of things that do have a
positive acute impact
and in this case you know i i won't say
that there's you know 100 percent slam
dunk evidence that an external
attentional focus
both improves acute performance and
those improvements in acute performance
necessarily lead to larger enhancements
in performance long term
but the evidence does at least lean in
that direction uh so there's there's
strong evidence that an external
attentional focus will acutely enhance
performance and i would say weak to
moderate evidence that that will also
lead to larger performance enhancements
over time